foreign
[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know
we're very glad when we get your
questions however we have a huge pile of
questions that we need to answer and
this is only a half hour program uh
every week so maybe we need to expand it
to an hour and even then it would be
difficult to answer all of the questions
but we do appreciate you sending the
questions we put them in order and we
answer them in the order in which they
come I have with me here Daniel Miranda
who is associate pastor of Fresno
Central Seventh-day Adventist Church as
well as helping us here as a volunteer
at Secrest unsealed we appreciate having
him here at least part-time I used to be
full-time but now he's part-time as a
volunteer so thank you for being here
Pastor Miranda I think if Passover for
me it is a pleasure to be in this
wonderful program which is one of our
favorites praise the Lord yes and I'm
going to ask Pastor Miranda if he would
have prayer for us after I give you the
information of where to send us the
questions
TV at some tv.org
once again the address the email address
is TV at some tv.org we'd be delighted
to get your questions there you see it
on the screen so please lead us in
prayer
please uh bow your heads with me as we
pray dear heavenly father we're trying
Heavenly thank you very much for this
new program that we have who I'd like to
know you know the questions that have
been sent and I pray that you may give
us the wisdom and the understanding to
answer these questions let it be not
only Theory but that these May lead us
into a deeper love for the scriptures
and that this knowledge May transform
Our Lives we pray all this in the name
of Jesus amen amen praise the Lord
well our first question is might just
take us the whole period if not more
because it's a multiple uh question that
is that is made here uh it was sent by
Anna lugube
and she says good day pastors
I would like to ask about the work of
Christ in two places the holy place and
the most holy place
then the second question is what was
Jesus work in the Holy place
then when Jesus went into the most holy
place in 1844 was the work in the Holy
Place completed or finished
and finally
or does he sometimes go back to the holy
place since in the Earthly Sanctuary the
high priest went into the most holy
Place once a year yes does this also
apply to Jesus if he doesn't go back to
the holy Place does he do the work of
the Holy place while in the most holy
place since people are being born every
day growing up and confessing their sins
so there's multiple Dimensions to this
question we probably need to go one by
one yes so the first one is
actually a what was Jesus work in the
Holy place
so this is a really good question that
will need a lot of time to answer
because they are ritual of the Holy
place or the tamid ritual that is
connected also with the work in the
courtyard
occupy is a big portion of the book of
Exodus and the Book of Leviticus as well
but let me go to Hebrews 9 where we find
a summary of the ritual of the Holy
place
in Hebrews chapter 9
verses and actually here we can cover
both because Paul here gives a summary
of the rituals in both Apartments
beginning with verse 1 the Bible says
then indeed even the first Covenant had
ordinances of divine service and the
Earthly sanctuary
for a tabernacle was prepared the first
part in which was the lampstand table
and the showbread which is called the
sanctuary and behind the second Veil the
part of the Tabernacle which is called
the holiest of all
which had the golden sensor and the Arc
of the Covenant overlaid on all sides
with gold in which were the golden pod
that had the Mana Aarons wrote about it
and the tables of the Covenant and above
it were the cherubim of Glory
overshadowing The Mercy Seat of these
things we cannot now speak in detail
now he says here now these things had
been thus prepared the priest always
went into the first part of the
Tabernacle performing the services now
what were the services the door
performing there were daily Services
of sacrifices that they that were
performed in the courtyard for example
the burned offerings the law
said that every morning and every
evening a burnt offering should be
offered besides that we have the sin
offerings we have
the work in the lamb stand that there
was fire burning continually also the
bread was continually before the lore
there was continual burning of incense
so these happened all year every day and
that's what the Bible calls the tamit or
the daily the daily services
so the main part of this
um ceremony has to do with the
intercession for the sins of the people
so that is the work of the Holy place
I don't think we can really understand
the work of the Holy place without first
understanding the work of the court and
you brought that out when you read about
the different sacrifices that were
offered in the court of the sanctuary
because basically the court represents
the Earthly Ministry of Christ the
period of his incarnation
and basically Jesus came to do two
things some other things as well but two
main things number one to live a sinless
life
because he had to weave a robe of
righteousness that we could claim as our
own in Repentance
but then he also had to solve the
problem that we not only need to be
covered with his righteousness we also
need to have our sins that punishment
for our sins satisfied and so after
Jesus lived his Immaculate life which is
represented by the lamb without blemish
then Jesus went to the cross and bore
the sins of the whole world
and when he goes into the holy place he
now applies the benefits amen that he
earned on Earth through his perfect life
and his death that's right just to
explain you know when when I repent and
of course the holy spirit gives me
repentance it's not something I come up
with when I repent and I confess my sins
and I trust in Jesus I say Lord I'm
really sorry for what I did
at that moment Jesus Takes his perfect
life and he puts it to my account and he
takes his death for sin and he puts it
to my account as well and God looks upon
me as if I had never sinned
so what Jesus does in the Holy place is
to apply to individuals who repent what
he gained in the court of the sanctuary
amen so you have a building pattern you
know the the holy Place Ministry depends
on the court and the most holy Place
Ministry depends on the holy place and
the court yes
so basically then we have the work of
Jesus
since 80 31 to 1844 was the work of
applying the merits of his saving
sacrifice to every repentant sinner yeah
and we have Bible verses for that we
have an advocate with the father uh
Hebrews chapter 7 verse 26 says he
always lives to make intercession for us
amen and Acts chapter 2 you know Peter
says repent and be baptized for the
Forgiveness of sins because sins were
not forgiven at the cross Jesus made
provision for forgiveness of sins at the
cross that is an important point the
very important distinction so uh from
the Ascension of Christ and his
installations high priest till 1844
Jesus is uh interceding for those who
come to God through him as it says in
Hebrews chapter 7. amen now now then
comes the key question because I think
we all understand and agree with the
holy place but then the most holy place
did Jesus cease to intercede
in the most holy places the question
that you read
or or he continues to intercede or in
order to intercede does he have to go
back to the holy place to continue the
intercession
that's a good question no actually on
the day of atonement the high priest
simply would take on an additional
function right he would still continue
interceding for sin for Sinners but he
picked up an additional function which
was the Judgment function
yeah and we see it in Leviticus 16 were
the
the priest in verse let's see verse
6.
verse 5 and 6 Leviticus 16 verses 5 and
it says and he shall take from the
congregation of the children of Israel
two kids of the goats as a sin offering
and one ran as a burnt offering Aaron
shall offer the bull as a sin offering
which is for himself and make atonement
for himself and for his house so here we
see intercession yes Aaron is making
atonement for himself he's making
atonement for his house as well and then
he does it for the people right right so
there is intercession but now
in Leviticus 16 in the day of atonement
we also see the cleansing of the
sanctuary which is a work of judgment so
as you said he only takes on an
additional function
but he still continues to intercede for
his people
and perhaps that's the reason why
uh in Hebrews the altar of incense is
oriented towards the most holy place
that's a good point even though it is in
the Holy place you know between the
altar of incense and the most holy place
there was a curtain and on the curtain
were embroidered Angels ascending and
descending on the Veil
which represents the fact that when
incense was offered the prayers of God's
people would go over the veil into the
most holy place and then God would send
his answers back to those who were
praying you know in Luke chapter 1
verses 8 through 10 we see that as well
as in Revelation chapter 8 verses three
to five right and so even though the
altar of incense was in the Holy place
its orientation was towards the most
holy place which which indicates that
sin could be forgiven in the Holy place
and sin could also be forgiven in the
most holy Place amen and in the in the
verse that I read which is Hebrews 9 4.
it is interesting that the golden sensor
is described as being part of the most
holy place
but not in place but in function right
it continues it's part of both the holy
place and the most holy Place yeah I
think sometimes we get too caught up in
geography yes and not on the meaning
that's right of geography Ellen White
interprets for example Jesus going into
the most holy place as beginning a new
ministration in other words that the
ministration I'm not denying that
there's a real
a tangible Heavenly Sanctuary but
sometimes we get so caught up in the
geography itself that we forget the
meaning of what's going on yes in that
particular apartment that's right yeah
so I I think that we answered all of the
questions you know maybe we can just
mention one further thing
um did Jesus
complete the atonement on the cross big
debate in the Adventist Church was
salvation complete finished at the cross
well the Bible says that Jesus on the
cross said it is finished
but Ella white says that Jesus went into
the holy place of the sanctuary to
continue the work of Salvation so how do
we understand uh you know Jesus saying
it is finished on the cross and still
carrying out administration of Salvation
in the Holy place right
well the Bible is clear that Jesus is
sacrificed on the cross was a perfect
sacrifice for sin
he made perfect provision
he defeated Satan on the cross and when
he said it is finished he is declaring
with that word that now Satan's power on
humanity is broken and Jesus has taken
back this world to himself that before
belonged to Satan it is like a death
blow to Satan before his actual
destruction but there is still a work of
atonement that needs to go on in the
sanctuary we're not the perfect
atonement that was provided at the cross
now as you said it is applied to the
Believers while he is still in the
century you know it's interesting
whenever I present some I have a whole
presentation where I deal with Christ's
Ministry all throughout the sanctuary
and when I come to the part where I say
I ask the question did Jesus forgive
everyone's sins at the cross
immediately you hear the roar yes
but technically that's not true
Universal legal justification no Jesus
made provision perfect provision
for whoever comes to claim uh the merits
of his sacrifice and the merits of his
life
so you know the Bible teaches that very
clearly that forgiveness comes when we
confess our sins if we confess our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive our
sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness amen so we have to come
to Jesus and claim what he did amen
okay I think basically we I answered
this question I hope the answer was
satisfactory uh here's another one uh
that uh we probably can answer pretty
quickly but we need to maybe expand a
little bit upon
is it okay to ride your bicycle on the
Sabbath I suspect that some young person
asked this question I'm not sure but
what can we say about that
well this kind of questions you're
tempted to to go into do's and don'ts uh
you do this you don't do this but um the
best thing would be to to present the
principle behind the Sabbath and every
person uh based on their own conscience
and judgment they should decide whether
it is okay or not uh well the Bible says
in in the book of Isaiah Chapter 58 yep
it gives us a principle it gives us the
principles people have to pray to the
Lord and ask the Lord for guidance in
applying the principle to individual
cases exactly so in Isaiah 58 we find a
principle for Sabbath keeping verse 13.
if you turn away your food from the
Sabbath from from doing your pleasure on
my holiday and call the Sabbath a
delight the holy day of the Lord
honorable and shall honor him not doing
your own ways not finding your own
pleasure not speaking your own words
so the principle that we find here is
that we should not do or seek our own
pleasure
on the Sabbath day now that can be
defined in different ways the burden of
the circumstances but on the other hand
um
we find a sum for the salad Psalm 92
we find another principle for
salvascaping which actually Jesus also
um
he kept
you know this is a sum for the Sabbath
and it says it is good to give thanks to
the Lord and to sing praises to your
name almost high to declare your loving
kindness in the morning and your
faithfulness in the evenings
um you know the the the the psalm is a
sum of Praise where God is exalted for
his creation and for his loving kindness
in Genesis 2 verses 1 through 3 we see
that the Sabbath is a commemoration of
his creating work so everything or
anything that connects us to God and
creation
it is also a principle for Sabbath
keeping I mean Sabbath keeping is not
only going to church but even Ellen
White herself says that we should spend
some hours contemplating the Creator
Creator creative works of God
you know also it's a sign of redemption
so we can focus on Redemption as well
amen
um you know on Sabbath we we can go in
the midst of Nature and see the
greatness of God in everything that is
created and then we can also Express
thankfulness because what we lost we are
going to regain regain by Recreation
amen so in other words the Sabbath we
can focus on creation we can focus on
Redemption and we can focus on the
Restoration in the future because we're
going to go from month to month and from
Sabbath to Sabbath to worship before the
Lord
I refuse to make lists of do's and
don'ts on the Sabbath
uh God has given us a conscience
and uh and if we don't deceive our
conscience or attempt to deceive our
conscience you know by justifying things
that are not justifiable
uh I think we'll be safe as long as
we're consecrated we we shouldn't be
like the scribes and Pharisees you know
they prescribed the last little itsy
bitsy detail of what you could do and
what you could not do on the Sabbath so
Ellen White states that it was
impossible to keep the Sabbath of the
Pharisees and by the way this is the
reason why uh Christian churches reject
the Sabbath because they're looking at
the Sabbath as being from the
perspective of the scribes and Pharisees
rather than the Sabbath of the Lord yes
you know I have an example of this
um when I was in Colombia teaching
theology I used to go to campouts with
the master guides and so I went uh to a
camp one time uh you know it wasn't that
in Medellin it was way down in a country
that was very hot
and they had all their khaki uniforms on
and you know the worship service went on
the worship service ended about 12 31
o'clock and it was scorching hot I mean
they were they were dripping wet and
there was this beautiful Crystal River
clean river that ran through the camp
and they were all looking at the river
we wonder whether we might be able to
get into the water and cool off and so
one of them comes and says Pastor board
do you think it would be okay for us to
to just sit in the water and cool off
and uh you know when I was a child my
parents told me no swimming
so I said what do I do in this dilemma
do I make them be miserable by not
allowing them to get into the water or
do or do I make an exception and tell
them that it's okay so what I said was
you know it's okay for you to get into
the water and sit there and talk about
spiritual things
but the moment that you start splashing
around and just uh playing in the water
at that moment you're all going to have
to come out and it was amazing they sat
there they talked about many spiritual
things they talked about the church and
they talked about the the meaning of the
Sabbath and so on and they were they
were all refreshed uh I don't think that
I did wrongly correct yeah you know and
there's also such a thing as uh we're
not supposed to buy or sell my parents
taught me that and the Bible says we're
not supposed to buy or sell
um but you know once in a while when you
have to buy a medicine for someone you
go to the pharmacy and you buy the
medicine because you you need to do good
on the Sabbath amen and so we need to be
very careful as everness that we're not
looked at as legalistic on the other
side we must be very careful not to
justify things by saying you know it's
okay to do this on the Sabbath God will
be okay with it so we just have to be
sincere
we have to pray and we have to be honest
with ourselves about what we do on
Sabbath whether it is God's will or
whether it's our will amen and that's
why what we said at the beginning of
this question it is important to have
the principles clear uh I I like the
examples that you gave perhaps I can
give one more example more the
um related to the bicycle issue
when I went to the Congo in 2014
we were visiting this region called
bandundu that there was no Adventist
presence or actually there was already
Adventist presence but the work has just
started so there was a brother from here
from the United States that he was
paying several Bible workers to go out
and give Bible studies and they couldn't
afford to have cars or motorcycles so
the Bible workers bought bicycles so on
Sabbath and and on other days they would
go on their bikes from Village to
Village to give Bible studies I don't
think that would be wrong no to take a
bike in order to move to another
location on the Sabbath day in order to
give a Bible study now if you start
doing raises on the Sabbath and all that
that's different yeah and mountain
biking yeah and doing things like that
that would be a different story right
but you know the Pharisees all the time
they were
questioning Jesus and the disciples you
know you have the example of Matthew
chapter 12 where the disciples were
going through a grain field and they
took some of the Grain and they they
partook of it on Sabbath and doesn't say
that Jesus did that but his disciples
did and so the Pharisees say why do you
allow your disciples to do what is not
right to do on the Sabbath well the
Bible doesn't say that you can't pick
some green uh you know to satisfy your
hunger in Sabbath but that wouldn't mean
that you can go out with your tractor
and harvest their field on the Sabbath
and so we need to be practical and we
need to be wise in not making the
Sabbath be a burden and that's one of
the reasons why youth are turned off is
because we make things so legalistic and
so miserable on the Sabbath like the
Pharisees did that they say they throw
out the baby with the bath water so to
speak yes that's so good anything else
that we can say about this question we
only have like about three minutes left
and we don't have time for the next
question uh yes well we can we can
conclude by saying that when it comes to
South keeping or any other commandment
you know the health
and other things like you know dress and
things like that we always need to
follow principles there is not sometimes
we want to put a distinction between
black and white and we want everything
to be that clear but it's not like that
all the time I mean real life most of
real real life takes place in a gray
area between black and white and now
we're not saying that we should be
neutral no but the same commandment or
law that I specify for a certain person
or a certain location doesn't work for
everyone and for all circumstances yeah
and that's why we need to have this
clear in our minds so that with an
enlightened mind and conscience we can
make the right decision yeah and you
know sometimes I think we misinterpret
some statements of Ellen White for
example she said uh you're not supposed
to take a bath on the Sabbath well if
you know the way that they took baths
back then it took a very very long time
to take a bath because they didn't have
running water like we do today
so you know would the council be
different today just you know if you've
been outside in the midst of nature
walking hiking and you're all sweaty do
you have to wait till Sundown to get a
bath today when it's just a matter of
turning on a faucet and taking a shower
another thing is cooking you know people
might disagree with what I'm going to
say but cooking was a major Endeavor
back in biblical they had to get the
wood and they had the light we had to
Fan the wood and then they had to put
the pan they hid the heat you know it
was took hours and hours today to heat
our food all we have to do is simply
turn on the burner and heat the food
that's right I don't think that God's
intention for us is to eat cold food
because we make the rule more important
than uh being in peace and enjoying the
Sabbath as a day of rest very good I
agree so anyway well our time is just
about up any Last Word of Wisdom pastor
well let us continue studying uh any
question that we might have we might not
find the answer specifically in the
Bible or the spirit of Prophecy but we
do find the answer in principle amen the
Bible even though it was written more
than 2 000 years ago still the
principles are up to date amen we should
take what was written back in those days
in under what circumstances what
principle I can draw I can draw from
that and how I can apply it today and
that all not only applies to the Sabbath
it applies to all of them all of The
Commandments because all of The
Commandments are very short principles
you know don't have any Idols well we
know that that extends to money it
extends to many things other than bowing
before an image of stone or gold or
silver and so let's learn to apply the
principles uh to our own lives and ask
the Lord for us to be sincere in doing
this well thank you so much for joining
us God bless you all hope to see you
next time on our question and answer
program I'd like to know
[Music]
foreign